yeah hi Sandra my name is Kevin and
you've got a great question here what do
you what am i doing specifically to
invest in innovation and job creation
run a company called serious materials
and what we've done is gone and rescue
old plants in the u.s. that that have
died for a variety of reasons we brought
back workers including union workers
brought them back to work gave them new
work to do and really the clean energy
economy making very advanced products to
make buildings energy efficient when we
look at innovation we look at innovating
uh you know the way we build buildings
the way we manage buildings which has
been the same for hundreds of years so
we've made huge strides in doing this
we're very very excited about it and and
so we've got great innovation we're
driving thirty forty fifty percent
savings and buildings and we're doing it
with putting people back to work in in
the u.s. at least so I hope that answers
your question that's what I'm doing
thank you so much